how's your brother's piece I'm very
excited cuz today we have some really
really cool game sports I'm excited like
stupid yes the first game is paint the
town break okay it starts up at at a bar
they all look very ready to fight I
don't know why all I wanted was to play
cubes I can't take much more of this
these guys are crazy and I think they're
onto me they've been made they have been
what I can't read fast enough game I
missed the joke my friend let's play
pool bad the day why did you play cubes
all right you know what
oh Jesus Christ I'm so sorry he had it
coming for him
oh my god I can pick this up and then I
could throw it oh gee I'm sorry
what the [ __ ] oh God let's take this
chair don't fight me I have a chair I
told you what is this a penis I got back
off I have a chair all right let's go
backstage always time to cook some
beaches me boom head chef this is
awesome you'll never get me alive [ __ ]
there we go
[ __ ] you up I shake you oh I want this
is why bloody games shouldn't be
censored what the [ __ ]
let's get to the stage [ __ ] yeah
I'm sorry mate I didn't mean that damn
it you don't [ __ ] with the way huh Oh
punch the music punch the music punch
the music bro you don't even happen how
are you play
[Music]
ha ha ha that makes me [ __ ] with the
chair this chair is the most leap
oh god his arm Oh God
this chair is a death weapon look at it
I poke you I poke you my oh oh oh oh hey
Lily potent damn son I'm sorry I'm so
sorry about your face bro oh god he
doesn't know what he's doing
you'll be handicapped for the rest of
your life it's my guitar my music sorry
violent video games just causes me to
freak out - machine oh God
can I play the drums damn it that was
paint the town be red ready fun game I
would rate it probably best game ever 10
to 10 yeah bad eye man just put your put
your butt on the screen you're welcome
if you thought that was weird
it's about to get weirder
this is a Japanese game so that's how
you know it's gonna be weird but this is
a weird Japanese game so that's how you
know it's gonna be so [ __ ] weird but
you might not come back it's the same
person you once once enter please Oh
pudding all right so I am punching a
girl why are you slapping me why you
stop hitting me god dammit oh I'm so
mean I can't help it though [ __ ] this
I'm against this don't punch women if
they are in a bathtub oh I don't really
[ __ ] her up man not in the way that you
think ah ah she she won what the Oh
all right there what does this do oh of
course we can choose a duck in there
best game ever came out of time
all the Ducks game oh god this is so
stupid oh I can just slap her all this
slapper it's only I did this sell missus
self-defense I'll scratch your [ __ ]
eyes out
oh that rapport in China 9 days to a guy
oh your axe
I hope my sin doesn't come in when I
play this this is what you get for
cheating on me with all these ducks hey
no don't block come on don't block hey
come on come on oh I'm sorry
she's sleeping hello yes 100% yes I
don't know what you're talking about
oh god what is this is horrible what the
[ __ ] is this what the hell baby shirt
damn it damn it she got away come back I
promise I won't punch you skate it's so
[ __ ] weird Oh what what what what
what I murderer
I'm a merger deadlier okay do you know
what video games video games are a thing
and some of them you probably just stay
away from that is probably the most
[ __ ] up big Mike Lee the third and
final games for this evening night
morning whatever the spots are doomed
the Big Bang
shut up heads the big bad wolf the big
back foots night one so you place the
werewolf oh no one sees anything no one
suspects a thing
what happened something happen under
this thing the Sun is going down I
better kill people [ __ ]
oh I better sit in this bush then damnit
mysterious death at Park Bench night -
mmm tastes like chicken
hey buddy yeah I'm a bush just kidding
why do they all look the same
you'd think this is a trap or some [ __ ]
but I'm the trap
oh no you take a picture of me [ __ ] that
better eat him what happened what does
that mean oh god damn it the arm is in
now oh [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] it all night they knew I made
that bush yeah yeah yeah just burnished
you found artful disguise what no way
hey Betty oh [ __ ]
I didn't eat [ __ ] Lord Wavell Lord
werewolf no way
why do people still come back to the
party if they know people get murdered
in it okay no witnesses no witnesses
no witness said our UFO Oh God it's
gonna be hard don't know pictures how
dare you take a picture of my bad angle
oh god damn it
they got evidence or amazing here okay
my artful disguise they'll never suspect
a thing
hello gentlemen checked out cheerio with
it my mind don't you know this is
there's a werewolf on the loose I will
just I'll just go here now
wolf makes break for freedom go werewolf
go lazy developers make world wrap
around oh that's fine just go wearable
oh oh oh [ __ ] oh that's a really cool
game I really I really like that one
hope you brothers enjoy today's game you
want you can suggest me which wants to
play it down below thank you for
watching as always to leave a like if
you want more and as always stay awesome
[Music]